it's terribly important that we see the
horrors of war because then we know
what's happening in our names if we
don't see it if that stuff is kept
secret then we're on our way to tyranny
hi I'm Zach white smaller with reason TV
we're here with Alex Gibney he's the
Academy award-winning filmmaker behind
such documentaries as taxi to the dark
side and run the smartest guys in the
room and most recently we steal secrets
the story of WikiLeaks in theatres May
twenty-fourth consequences of the
release of these documents are
potentially severe and danny has
detained a US soldier in connection with
the link of this classified video the
sort of aging student Hobart was a rock
star changing phones and phantom
computer it's not that WikiLeaks it's by
transparency who gets to control
information we steal secrets is not only
a compelling history of WikiLeaks from
its beginnings to present day it's also
a really fascinating psychological
portrait of both Julian Assange and
Bradley Manning what made you decide to
tell this story and why did you focus so
much on the personalities behind it when
I first started this story I thought it
was a story about two things one it was
a David and Goliath story about one guy
an itinerant a hacker who was wrong in
the world who had this device an
electronic Dropbox for leaking secrets
well it turned out that that machine
wasn't so important as I thought it was
that actually this whole process of
leaking sources and secrets has a lot
more to do with a human dynamic then
then I really initially gave a credit
for it a lot of it has to do with
Bradley Manning that was the other
aspect of it as i began to you know move
to tell more of the Bradley Manning
story which is tricky because we didn't
have access to him because he was locked
up by the US military Bradley Manning is
someone that for instance famous
whistleblower Daniel Ellsberg called
heroic he kind of comes across as heroic
in your film this is a guy who's been in
prison for three years just awaiting a
trial a military trial he was in
solitary confinement for nine
months what do you think about how
Manning has been treated throughout the
whole thing we can agree that we don't
want all of our soldiers to be will
Eenie luton nilly leaking documents all
the time he took an oath he broke that
off and he's actually pled guilty to it
but the charges of aiding the enemy and
violation of the Espionage Act and so
forth the way they're trying to send him
to prison for the rest of his life and
frankly they said they're not going to
seek it but they could give him the
death penalty it's outrageous after they
leaked the documents related to the
Afghanistan war the government did not
react to the New York Times publishing
this information their focus was on
wikileaks what do you make of that
reaction it's easier for them to react
particularly the Obama administration
considered a liberal administration to
react against this strange website
running by a hacker rather than against
the New York Times or The Guardian or
dear Spiegel the German publication but
I think also in that case Julian was his
own worst enemy because this inability
to properly redact names from the Afghan
war logs left Assange and WikiLeaks
vulnerable to attack Assange would say
that he tried to redact and I mean he
even sent documents to the Pentagon and
they wanted nothing to do with that yeah
he sent he said the documents to the
Pentagon 24 hours before publication I
think it's genuine it was disingenuous
Julian's great character flaw was that
he had this moment in history and it
turned out he wasn't humble enough or
willing enough to learn from others to
put himself in the best possible
situation in this incredibly important
moment we had Admiral Mullen saying that
Julian Assange might have blood on his
hands and you're saying if he had
handled it somehow differently they
might not have been able to pin it on
him so so easily yes I think Julian
Assange played in to the US government's
hands by not properly redacting those
Afghan war logs because then they
wouldn't have been able to say he had
blood on his hands now that was a
talking point and it was overwrought and
it was full of baloney in some way be
after all a lot of people dying in
Afghanistan there are a lot of people
dying in Iraq there was a really
interesting moment in the documentary
when the title itself is referenced and
your kind of expecting it to come from
someone associated with WikiLeaks but it
comes from the former CIA director
Michael Hayden nation-states need to be
secret in order to be successful we
steal secrets we the US government we
steal secrets and he's kind of almost
proud of it and he wants to be open
about the stealing of secrets he feels
like he has the moral high ground and
then WikiLeaks is doing the same thing
what they're doing is bad exactly I mean
that's the irony and that's them if you
want the poetry of the title we steal
secrets the fact is that Michael Hayden
can sit there and tell me that and he's
telling me that look this is just
pragmatics this is what we do it's what
all governments do we spy on each other
and we steal secrets okay does that mean
it's okay for anybody to do it when is
it okay to do it and and then why is it
that we can charge bradley manning with
crimes that might lead him to be put to
death for doing what the united states
government admits doing itself it raises
all these interesting questions and and
they're never properly answered the
elephant kind of not in the room is
Julian Assange himself and in the
documentary you say that he wanted you
to pay a million dollars to interview
him what was that like meeting with him
talking with him about that and was your
reaction when when he laid out these
demands but the conversations always
seem to be about you know I want to make
sure that you're on side I want to make
sure that I was spreading the WikiLeaks
gospel that's not really my job one
point he said look you should pay me for
an interview like this and the going
rate for an interview with me the market
radii think he said was a million
dollars I said well you know I wasn't
going to dispute his view of the market
but it said I don't pay for interviews
so that's not really said well that
doesn't work how about this how about
you spy he said give intel on all the
other interview subjects and report back
to me and I
it struck me as deeply ironic that this
you know transparency radical was now
asking me to spy on people he supposedly
had sex with two women without a condom
they wanted him to use a condom and then
they filed charges to try to bring him
back to Sweden when he was in the United
Kingdom he says that this is perhaps a
plot to extradite him to the United
States from Sweden but you don't buy
that we know that there is a grand jury
investigation of Julian Assange but
there's no proof that the United States
government has somehow made a secret
deal with a Swedish government to
extradite Julian Assange as soon as he
goes to Sweden so there there is some
fishy timing in terms of when these
charges came out do you see that is
because they came out right after a big
one of his big document dumps do you see
that as a coincidence or there's no
doubt that they were fishy and I have to
tell you that when I first started this
story I found the whole Swedish affair
to be wildly suspicious yeah I frankly
assumed that it was some kind of CIA
honey trap because the timing was just
outrageous yeah and so I did look into
it in that regard but the fact is that
nobody's been able to present any
evidence to me that as I said there's
any secret agreement between the United
States and the Swedish government but do
you think that he I mean I guess it's a
nobody will notice he believed it or I
think he probably he may believe it and
i think julian has come to believe his
own fiction after 911 there was a
massive classification of documents
there's more secret information now than
ever do Assange and Manning and
WikiLeaks signal the end of that it's
the beginning of a battle that's going
to be ongoing governments particularly
the US government but all governments
really have enormous powers in order to
surveil us in order to be able to find
out secrets and then to classify them
and now I think radically over classify
them but at the same time citizens have
now the ability as we know from
WikiLeaks to counteract that the
WikiLeaks cables which are really the
Manning cables we're
hugely important in terms of giving fuel
to the fire that became the Arab Spring
because it showed that US diplomats
recognized deep corruption abuse of
power that was being practiced by these
tyrants in the Middle East it pulled
back the curtain in a wizard of oz
fashion in a way that I think was
terribly valuable and obviously the the
great example of the collateral murder
video it's terribly important that you
see the horrors of war because then we
know what's happening in our names if we
don't see it if that stuff is kept
secret then we're on our way to tyranny